BUT FIRST, THERE'S
BREAKING NEWS IN THE CASE
OF L.A. CLIPPERS OWNER
DONALD STERLING.
HE HAS COME UNDER FIRE FOR HIS
THOUGHTS ON THE
INSTAGRAM-ABILITY OF -- OF I
GUESS YOU WOULD CALL IT
GIRLFRIEND AND BLACK PERSON
FRIENDSHIP.
>> EFFECTIVE IMMEDIATELY, I AM
BANNING MR. STERLING FOR LIFE.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Jon: YES!
>> FROM ANY ASSOCIATION WITH THE
CLIPPERS ORGANIZATION OR THE
NBA.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
♪
>> Jon: WOW.
SO MUCH EXCITEMENT OUT THERE.
SO MUCH EXCITEMENT OUT THERE
FROM THE ENTIRE WORLD AND EVEN
APPARENTLY THE PAST.
[ LAUGHTER ]
IT'S GOOD TO SEE THE DISTINCTION
BETWEEN FREE SPEECH AND
CONSEQUENCE FREE SPEECH.
MY GUESS IS THIS IS NOT THE
DEATH NELL FOR THIS COUNTRY'S
LONG AND PROUD TRADITION
OF CRAZY TALK.
>> IF I WERE IN CHARGE --
[LAUGHTER]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Jon: ALL I CAN SAY THERE
IS THANK GOD THAT IS A
HYPOTHETICAL.
>> THEY WOULD KNOW THAT
WATERBOARDING IS HOW WE BAPTIZE
TERRORISTS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> JON: HUH?
THAT IS SARAH PALIN GIVING A
SPEECH WHERE SHE IS SOMEHOW
CONFLATING A SACRAMENT OF HER
FAITH
WITH TORTURE IN ORDER TO SOMEHOW
BRING THE FEAR OF GOD TO
RELIGIOUS EXTREMISTS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I DON'T EVEN -- WHERE IS THAT
SPEECH EVEN APPROPRIATE AT AN AL
QAEDA RECRUITMENT HOW-TO VIDEO
WORKSHOP?
AT THE YEARLY GATHERING OF THE
DUMMOLOS OR MAYBE SHE'S GIVING
ONE OF THOSE FAMED HUH TALKS.
THEY ARE LIKE TED TALKS EXCEPT
THEY MAKE NO SENSE.
WELL, SO -- TED TALKS.
[LAUGHTER]
SO, WHAT ELSE DID THE FORMER
VICE PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE OF
ONE OF TWO MAJOR NATIONAL
PARTIES TELL WHOEVER IT IS SHE
IS TALKING TO.
>> JOE BIDEN, REMEMBER THIS HE
TELLING WOMEN BEFORE AN ASSAULT
JUST A FIRE WARNING SHOT UNTIL
THE COPS SHOW UP.
JUST AIM UP IN THE AIR.
THAT WAS HIS DIRECTIVE.
HIS ADVICE.
WELL FINE, JOE SQUIRT GUN, IF
YOUR RAPIST IS A BIRD.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jon: SHE SEEMS NICE.
SO I SEE.
WELL, THE FORMER ALASKA GOVERNOR
WITH A CLEAR AND QUITE RYE
REFERENCE TO THE WELL KNOWN
GREEK MYTH LEDA AND THE SWAN.
ZEUS IN THE FORM OF A SWAN
FORCED HIMSELF ON LEDA
DAUGHTER OF THESTIUS, KING OF
AETOLIA LEADING TO THE BIRTH OF
HELEN OF TROY YADA YADA YADA
SMASH CUT CHRISTOPHER COLUMBUS
DISCOVERS AMERICA AND THUS THE
FOUNDING FATHERS CREATE THE
GREATEST COUNTRY GOD HAS EVER
GIVEN TO THE PEOPLE OF EARTH.
WELL PLAYED, GOVERNOR, YOU DO
READ, ALL OF THEM.